الصوت الخميس لن يعبر الآسيوي
القبائلية المؤرضة هي سمة للنساء
العرب ولعب الحياة على حساب
لقد تم تناول إعلان منطقة البحر الكاريبي
الشخص وهو معقد أيضًا
الطلاب الجدد القادمين الذين
ليس لديهم المعرفة التي ليس لديهم
من الأصدقاء أو ما تشعر به
وحدنا لذلك ليس لدينا خيار نقبله
إما أنها الرموز الملزمة ستكون
محبط حقا ولكن
[موسيقى]
في الواقع إذا كان يستطيع أن يأتي إلى الحياة
موجة لا ربما عليك ذلك
اذهب إلى هناك وعليك أن تعرف أين لا تعرف
يشفي لا نريد أن نشفى إذا كان الأمر يستحق
من الأفضل أن تفعل شيئًا في ثلاثة أو
أربعة أسابيع من التمديد
حتى عطلة عيد الميلاد سوف يجتمع في
عيد الميلاد ليس سيئا بالفعل
اللعبة كل يوم خميس من ألنتو كجم إلى
تصميم عجلات الكمبيوتر قليلا
غريب ولكن هذا هو الحال أمام
نغمات لاندرو المزيفة لمارك آدامز بيتي
مدرسة ماجنا ولكن الدنماركيين هذا
العام كان سيارة أجرة إلى المنطاد الديناميكي
وألفا بيتا هالو منظمة العفو الدولية لابنتي
سيدتي أرليت وجيرارد